in a sprawling camp of canvas and wire
for displaced people in syria there is a
special section
for the members and associates of
islamic state
a camp of the damned occupied by the
women and children of is
fighters and there are 1500 people
packed inside we want to go back
we won't go out from here i was met at a
padlocked gate
by camp residents who were both curious
and angry
i'd like to hear trinidad's view on what
they think about their people bringing
here
here there's over at least 90
trinidadian children in syria
why is trinidad vionda for over 90 kids
they say nothing
do they care about the people are they
even concerned that's it
yes i just want to know if france will
take
us take you out of the camp yes
what do you think people in france would
say if you returned home
would do would you be welcomed do you
think
no i think no
they are the survivors women and
children who've swapped the so-called
caliphate
for this badly crowded camp and the
conditions here
are poor
[Music]
i watched as residents begged for food
medicine and assistance
in a multitude of different languages
there is three
children from south africa and the
mother is
the mother she uh she's mentally
sick okay we try to take her to the
doctor but there is no they cannot do
nothing
the 19 year old britain shamima begum is
held in this section
and i was told that she'd been moved
overnight
we found her down by the fence line and
she said she was ill
and the camp had lost her papers
right now i don't have my car because
they've lost my card so i have to run
around
you know take care of my son when i'm
sick
[Music]
okay the home secretary
says he'll revoke her british
citizenship but he's indicated that
shamima begum's newborn son
can return would you be prepared to let
the sun
go to the uk if he
to the politicians in the uk is there
anything you you want to say
you know i would like to re-evaluate my
case with a bit
do you think you can change can you
rehabilitate these women were drawn to a
utopian fantasy
propagated by islamic state but it's
ended
in de facto imprisonment and no one
knows
how long they'll have to stay the
residents or
the inmates in that section are
completely cut off
now they haven't heard from family
members or officials in their home
countries
they really have no idea what is going
on
and everybody is asking for help but no
one except for the kurds
are prepared to provide it kurdish-led
forces
who maintain this facility want
countries like the uk
to take their citizens away but the
regional commander told us
no one from the british government has
contacted them
john sparks sky news in northern syria